in the philippines
an illegal gold trade worth an estimated
700 million us dollars a year
is flourishing
operated by shadowy financiers agents
and buyers
who would use any means to keep their
business going
while the industry leaves a trail of
destruction
we find the people fueling this illegal
trade
find out how the illegal gold changes
hands
and follow its trail to its final
destination
in the philippines
uh
[Music]
just east of manila by the coast of the
pacific ocean
is the town of paraquali also known as
gold town
[Music]
foreign
foreign
this sleepy town is home to a highly
profitable gold mining and processing
industry
and many are trying
jeremy is a minor in an illegal gold
mine
it is all that he has ever known
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
six days a week jeremy makes this 30
minute journey to panganiban
foreign
hidden under the cover of a mangrove
swamp an
illegal gold mining site is in operation
these sites supply gold for the black
market trade
miners like jeremy are known as players
they work at these mines without any of
the necessary permits
here the players practice compressor
mining
the most dangerous form of gold mining
in the world
it is also illegal in the philippines
in compressor mining miners have to work
underwater for long hours to get to the
gold
buried deep underground they breathe
through a narrow rubber tube
that is connected to a compressor
the pits are dug close to a river so
they fill up with water as soon as
miners dig a meter in
despite the dangers the miners only have
the most
basic equipment to work with
foreign
it is almost pitch black and it is
at foreign bottom jeremy is only able to
feel his way around with his hands
[Music]
he digs for rocks and puts them into a
bag
which is then dragged up the shaft with
the rope by his friend
on the surface
the rocks are inspected and the ones
with gold are kept aside
their income fluctuates from day to day
foreign
players like jeremy are at the very
bottom rung of an elaborate
illegal network they answer to the
people operating above them
the financiers
here
the financiers work behind the scenes
pulling the strings
they are the bosses behind the
operations who are willing to break the
law
to keep their business going
i said
[Music]
in the philippines people have been
working at these illegal gold mines for
decades
behind the scenes it is the financiers
who fund these shadowy operations
they are responsible for assembling the
crew and deciding on the mining location
we tracked down a financier
we're in a small town neighboring
paracali
[Music]
peninsula
for an investment of about 1 000 us
dollars to set up an illegal mine
the financiers can expect to double
their investment or more
if they strike gold
despite operating illegally the
financiers do not worry about being
shut down by the authorities some have
been paid
to turn a blind eye
local officials
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
rock mills are the next link in the
black market gold trade
in parakali hidden behind a small bike
workshop
we find an illegal rock milling
[Music]
operation
financiers bring their rocks to places
like these
to separate the gold from the rocks
[Music]
mercury is an extremely toxic metal and
direct contact with mercury
can lead to toxic poisoning
but the workers here seem to
underestimate the dangers
foreign
the next step of the process is equally
dangerous
workers heat up the mixture to separate
the raw gold
from the mercury
without any safety precautions workers
here risk respiratory failure
all for as little as five us dollars a
day
open five grams
[Music]
for some the cost of extracting this
small amount of gold
only surfaces years later and
it is a huge cost
[Music]
jerry has been working in illegal gold
mines in paracali for the past
20 years but in the past three
months he hasn't been able to work
[Music]
that was
foreign
up
[Music]
[Music]
yes
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
while the miners deal with the impact on
their health
agents who act as middlemen between
financiers and buyers
are profiting
now the agents get the raw gold
processed before it can be sold
the gold is refined by trained chemists
in illegal processing sites
we scale the ball
1.2 grams mix in
allah or what no
the raw gold needs to be refined to
remove impurities
[Music]
degrees
already cookie yeah
that's okay i'll pick the gold
and
it's done it's finished
it's almost 24k gold
the refined gold is now ready to be sold
but who in parakale is buying the
illegally mined gold
in parakali in the philippines illegal
gold mining has gone on for decades
involving miners who risk their lives
for as little as four us dollars a day
and financiers and agents who rake in
much
bigger profits
these fake shops are fronts for trading
in illegally mined
gold
nato we
follow the agent with hidden cameras to
see
where he sells his goal
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
while the players at the bottom of the
hierarchy make little more than
four us dollars a day the agents
can make more than 10 times that amount
in a single transaction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay with so many cashing in
the illegal gold mining industry has
left scars
on the land
[Music]
[Music]
environmental activist arkhan prera grew
up
in parakali
[Music]
devastated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mercury
foreign
forever that that the rights of our
people to a clean and healthy
environment
should be the main discerning factor for
whatever
for the lgus gina lopez is an
environmentalist and the former
secretary of the department of
environment and natural resources
the philippine clean water act she has
long been a vocal opponent against
mining in the philippines
accusing the industry of destroying the
environment
so it's more functional and it's more
answerable
i'm going to work if you allow the
destruction of the environment in one
area
you you kill the possibilities in other
areas because the way the ecosystem
works it's like a domino effect
you know then forget about the farmers
and fishermen just the people who want
the gold they're just
going to be the ones to make the money
and that gold is not there forever
so once they finish all the gold
reserves what's going to happen
what's going to happen to the future you
killed the land
so i feel the best use of philippine
resources
is to use it in a way that it can be
forever used
you don't kill it for now and never mind
what happens in the future and and
and i will say the blame of this
small-scale mining this gold is the
government
one they're not monitoring well and it's
not enough to say no
if people are poor and you're telling
them they can't do this you have to give
them an alternative
you can say why don't you do this and
you have to help them all the way up to
marketing until they make money
whose duty is it to make sure that
things happen well
government whose duty is it to make sure
that
uh illegal things don't happen
government whose duty is it to make sure
that our poor don't suffer
government so if government makes
choices to benefit the rich
what will the poor do
[Music]
many illegal miners continue putting
their lives and health at risk for the
sake of their families
gina lopez believes that the persistence
of illegal mining
is not down to poverty alone she feels
that the problem lies at the very top
where some in the government have a
vested
interest in mining activities
the governor the congressman their
families
operate the minds hello my god
i mean there are people that are
represented in
congress and whatever that that
themselves have mining interests
in the philippines mining funds
political campaigns
so every time you find a political
campaign that particular politician is
indebted to you
politicians consistently make decisions
that cater to business interests even if
it means the violation of filipino
rights
it's really really sad
[Music]
while agents are small time dealers who
operate mostly in
shops around town the sellers operate in
the larger market
buying and selling in larger quantities
[Music]
we track down a black market seller
who reveals where the illegal gold is
usually sold
[Music]
[Music]
market
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we follow the trail of illegal gold from
paraquali
to manila
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
gold is being illegally mined in
parakale
in the philippines but most of the gold
end up approximately 350 kilometers away
in binondo manila's chinatown
binondo is well known for its many
legitimate gold traders
but according to sources from parakali
some of the traders in binondo are also
big-time
buyers of illegally mined gold
by law local gold producers in the
philippines
must sell their gold to the central bank
but many prefer to do their business at
this black market
we set up an undercover operation to
talk to a buyer
at the black market you guys ready
we are ready is it filming now
scrolling yes
[Music]
we spot a man standing around
suspiciously
posing as interested gold sellers we
approach him
black market dealers here routinely buy
refined gold without
asking for any documentation to verify
its source
and illegal practice in the philippines
the agent offers to introduce us to his
boss a big-time
gold buyer
[Music]
around
[Music]
his boss is waiting in a quiet corner
behind a row of legitimate jewelry shops
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the buyer becomes suspicious and ends
the deal of brooklyn
we decide to leave before our cover is
blown
[Applause]
it is estimated that in 2012 90
of the gold from small-scale mining in
the philippines
was traded on the black market and sold
overseas
it's green it's green
it is green because you don't need the
gold
you don't need the gold but our people
need water our people need food our
people need air
and it is wrong for the government to
allow greed
to put at risk the lives of our people
it is wrong it's against our
constitutional rights
for some the demand for gold has
devastated their lives forever
[Music]
[Music]
foreign that afternoon
the mines at barangay polanas collapsed
killing julie's husband and three other
miners who were working
[Music]
underground
[Music]
the financier of the illegal mine
offered julie
cash in exchange for her silence
with no other means to support her
family
julie accepted the money
it was not an easy decision
[Music]
[Music]
the authorities attempted to track down
the financier of the mine
but he was never found and nobody was
held accountable for the accident
until today julie is still haunted by
the tragedy
[Music]
this tragedy prompted a major
investigation into the dangers of
compressor mining
it resulted in the philippine senate
passing a nationwide ban
on small-scale gold mining
but in parakale illegal gold mining
continues
[Music]
since 2012 it has claimed 10
more lives
despite laws banning small-scale mining
it is likely to continue if enforcement
is lacks
and when there are simply no
[Music]
alternatives
[Music]
[Music]
you